let's read the first story texas is
running out of food as weather crisis
disrupts
supply chain texans running low on food
are finding
empty grocery store shelves food
pantries are running out of supplies
and the freeze has wiped out substantial
portions of the state's citrus and
vegetable crops
this is from texas tribune they say the
state's week of weather health started
with a 133 car pileup outside of fort
worth a winter storm unlike any texas
has ever seen quickly followed
and seven days later millions are
without power and reliable water
they want to mention here's a quote it
was out of uh
someone uh some are sorting storing the
remaining rations and coolers outside
and trips to the grocery store often do
little to replenish pantries saying
quote
it was out of meat eggs and almost all
the milk before i left
crystal porter an austin resident said
about her local target
which she visited monday lines were
wrapped around the store when we arrived
shelves were almost fully cleared for
potatoes meat eggs and some dairy
two days later one of porter's neighbors
went to that same target
and the store was completely out of food
with no sign of additional shipments
arriving
or employees restocking shelves now this
is where where emergencies get scary
you know we we we've had stories like
this in the past there was one story
about an algal bloom in
in ohio i think it was and within an
hour of the news breaking
all bottled water was gone now the
difference here with texas is that
i mean this has been going on for what
almost a week now where the power's gone
out millions are without power
people are freezing and now people don't
have food so i guess
i'm curious uh dan because you know
you're the energy guy
if you want to just let's just have a
conversation why why is there no food
what's going on
there's no food because there's no
energy i mean energy does make the world
go around
you think of the amount of energy
required to bring in
uh via rail via truck to restock those
shelves right
when the energy supply disappears
everything else will go with it and
that's why you know i i get very excited
about energy i love this issue we were
talking about it
you know i can become a real geek on it
but it literally is the
the foundation of all of our life we're
all here because we were able to get
here
somehow through energy right we were
able to get in our cars if you took
public transportation which i know
none of us i definitely didn't right but
people who are listening to us right now
people who are watching us right now
from the very first thing you did this
morning think about it at least for me
the very first thing i did was turn off
my my iphone alarm yep
energy the last thing i will do and when
i set my alarm to make sure it's on even
though it's supposed to replace i always
check
i will turn off the light let's uh let's
get a little bit more specific they they
mentioned that food crops
are failing well that's simply a lack of
energy it's not the same kind of energy
we're you know we're talking about when
talking about fuels for vehicles but
cold weather is essentially energy
levels going down now their food is
failing
but also i think outside so we'll
definitely talk about the energy issues
i think that's important because
everyone wants to know what's going on
with the electricity yeah
but it was an ultimate ultimately in a
lot of ways there was
governmental failure here i mean they
didn't prepare properly for how to deal
with winter weather and there are some
jurisdictions bordering texas
where you can actually see you know it's
uh in arkansas i think there they
this image where you can see the roads
are plowed and then in texas it's just
snow all over the streets yeah and and
that's the problem of of of government
right it doesn't always work i'm not a
fan of government i'm not an anarchist
but
i have deep skepticism of government i
dislike government i don't trust
government at all levels
um so that is clearly a huge government
failure right
and the problem is we turn over so many
of these things
are our kids education we turn over
entire swathes of our society
because we assume government's going to
be in charge of it and then when
government fails at their job we say
well now to whom do i turn
you know who's not getting made fun of
today all those preppers
yeah right all those people who were
working i i see and you brought it up
not me
it's the craziest thing to me because i
did a promo for uh uh
these food bins sometimes i did a promo
earlier today on my main channel
and it's funny how that's supposed to be
like i see these leftists these
tribalists saying like haha tim's
selling food bins and i'm like is that
supposed to make me upset i don't
understand
yeah am i supposed to be like yes people
should not prepare for emergencies
am i am i going to mock somebody for
buying a fire extinguisher people in
texas don't got food right now
but the people who listen to me do yeah
i would even posit that the
a blizzard is a natural disaster like
this is i've never really thought of a
heavy snow as a natural disaster but
it's like a hurricane or absolutely you
know
completely devastating how many people
died 40 some people have already died
yeah last i saw i think the number was
40 41 wow
37 so yeah to say the government's not
prepared is definitely an understatement
here
and what what you were talking about
here is of course arkansas and texas
there's a viral photo going around of
the same
road and right on the border you see in
arkansas
the roads plowed in texas snow
everywhere and this is in part why a lot
of trucks
are not able to go to the supermarket
you have to understand
major cities are extremely vulnerable
because if the roads shut down
your food's not going to be getting to
you to your community especially in very
congested areas texas did not invest in
snow plows
arkansas did arkansas is used to dealing
with this and this is another reason why
again as i've been saying you need to be
personally responsible for yourself
more than ever i've been selling those
food buckets for years now
and people are like what are you doing
you're fearing i'm like no you know you
don't understand
like how vulnerable everything
is in our society and how in a matter of
seconds everything can be taken away and
you're only responsible for yourself
absolutely and and what annoys me about
our discourse is that then when we do
have an election
we will hem and haw as to whether or not
as governor will you allow
this six-year-old girl to identify as a
boy and play gymnastics and you say
can we talk about preparation for for
the next storm right can we talk about
the electric grid can we
these aren't infrastructure yeah they're
not sexy topics they're boring they're
nerdy they put everyone to sleep
but this is what government should be
doing and instead we have we have these
whole sessions about these
little mine and i don't need to minimize
the trauma of that six-year-old kid but
i'm
saying that is not the role of
government if government did its
darn job but it doesn't what texas
needed to do
was i don't know buy salt plows
issue notices to residents saying in the
event of winter weather make sure you
turn your water on
i can't believe all of these videos i've
seen it's crazy where the pipes burst
and i'm like it was a two-second thing
you walk over and you go
and you walk away or even just a little
bit
more than addressing school yeah you got
to teach little kids that i mean i get
texas is not used to winter weather like
this
but we had forecasts we knew this was
coming this is an absolute failure of
government 100
now on the energy front we're hearing
you know
the win the wind turbine thing i love
this one
so i saw a bunch of posts from
conservatives saying that wind turbines
froze
and this is the reason that the power
essentially went out in
in texas then i saw people on the left
saying
wind turbines operate in antarctica and
the real
problem was the gas lines we need a
green new deal and this proves it
i think the craziest thing was uh
patrick moore who is one of the founders
of greenpeace he's no longer
with the organization he basically said
something the effect of
climate catastrophes can't explain away
this record winter cold
and the weirdest thing is it's really
hard to to discuss
when you know we have all of this fake
news coming out
so there's a video going viral of snow
and i guess saudi arabia or something
like that yeah
and they're like oh look at this there's
camels and there's snow on them
and yeah apparently fact checkers are
saying that's actually normal
sometimes it snows especially in higher
altitudes like what do you what are you
saying like
deserts get cold so for some reason
though these people just believe these
things not doing any fact checking but i
want to pull up something
that i'm absolutely thrilled to show all
of you over on reddit's r slash
face palm there's a post that is one of
the most
upvoted reddit posts on the page and it
says
science s-i-e-n-s-e
making fun of uh tucker carlson i
suppose and it just took a carlson quote
he says quote it got cold last night and
the windmills froze
and as a result millions of texans are
freezing several have died
and then underneath it is an image and
it says meanwhile in antarctica
and it does a bunch of penguins standing
around and there are a bunch of wind
turbines
and what appears to be a giant glass
structure of some sort with solar panels
on it
i love this this image is it appears on
r
slash face palm so i don't know if
they're
uh self-aware and the face palm is
actually that
they're that the the antarctica thing is
fake
or that we're supposed to make fun
trucker carlson i'm assuming
they're making fun of tucker carlson by
pointing out there's actually wind
turbines in antarctica
here's the best part that's a fake image
wow it's
it's so obviously fake though there's
there's a picture look at these penguins
okay
for those that can see this because
there might be for the people listening
i'll explain to you
there are some penguins they're standing
around doing penguin stuff and then
there's a wind turbine
and standing right next to the wind
turbine is a penguin which stands i
believe what what about a foot and a
half tall
scroll down a bit scroll down yeah cause
you can't see it's behind your head
oh i see i see there you go perfect so
here's here's a little penguin and
they're about they're about a foot and a
half tall i think is it
maybe i'm wrong maybe a foot that's a
good guess yeah yeah about a foot in
half
and standing next to this wind turbine
and if you were to take this penguin
it would the wind turbine's like 15 feet
tall
i don't know if you've ever seen a wind
turbine or turbine blades
what are they like 200 feet oh they're
50 something like that no no they're
hundreds of people
yeah there are hundreds of hundreds so i
don't know how big these penguins are
man but this would mean this penguin's
like 20 feet tall
but then there's a guy in the background
too who and this is this is the best
part
the guy is standing next to to penguins
and these penguins are half as tall as
he is
so these are like two and a half three
foot tall maybe
maybe it looks i'm not a penguin
scientist okay maybe it's a gmo monsanto
penguin
yeah maybe that's it you know what i was
supposed to brush up on my penguin yeah
yeah before this so hold on let me let
me let me go further
so i i did a simple image search it was
not hard to do
the image comes from some italian
uh architecture design
event where they had an exhibit and uh
yes
someone was conceptualizing a plan for
green energy in
antarctica the image is not real you
need only
google search it and see it's a
wallpaper that you can buy
you know i did i took the image loaded
it into google image search and this
popped up
they're sharing a fake image to mock
tucker carlson
and they're saying face palm as if
tucker is the one who was wrong
yeah now i still i i did read a lot of
what tucker said
and tucker was i think he should have
been more clear about what was causing
the failure
but the point he was making is that
these these renewable energies are
unreliable
and he's correct thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you